good evening everyone welcome to this
lecture about my my pain food purchase
losses ever still it's hard to tell it's
not that hard to talk about this
constant console you always remember
your worst losses and other to those
moments as it's just start hitting chest
like why do I play this game I mean I
could just yeah there I don't know have
a beer hang out with my friends I don't
know watch TV what I'm doing with this
game on me it's very humbling you know
losing inches is very humbling because
you can play soccer or football can say
this guy made a mistake or the referee
made a mistake or day but you know in
chess is all on you it's all on you it's
very very humbling ok I thought what
what should I choose that people would
believe that I really talking about my
my greatest losses actually because it's
been such a long time as a consistent
came from 2004
I already cannot express the feeling
besides it was at a time that I was on
the rise my ego was going growing I
think was a hiccup but it was a very
untimely hiccup in my my rise to become
a gym so I was so under school I was I
didn't have any norms or something I was
23 50 feet day so in a year time I was
in I am and the year time after less
than a year time after I was a GM and I
think I got very close to 24 6070
strength by this time in 28th of April
2004 but then this was a this was a very
long time to hiccup in my rise to on my
way to become a GM and I thought ok you
know you always have these issues in
chest talking about that there is some
sort of a sexism going on and we do not
respect ladies enough and I chose the
game I lost against the lady
so Maria Volterra I didn't know if she
still placed yes I haven't seen her in a
tournament I think after 2006 I think I
saw her playing
at the Olympia in 2006 in Torino but I'm
not sure even about that but yeah but I
usually best anyways so this is round 9
I had a greater start in this tournament
so I'm as you can see I'm 24 36 and I
was my highest rating ever by far that
was the was the second time in my life I
was crossing 2,400 and and I won against
25 ATGM then I drew a 2600 with black
then I played a very good game against
another team I lost then I started
beating the low rated players I'm losing
to the higher rated ones and ok I I was
I didn't have a chance to score and a GM
norm so I was a bit despondent but not
much and I was Silvana kind of an even a
score so you had I won this game my elo
we have gone up actually maybe a couple
of points or something I was still about
I mean if I went maybe two three I don't
know anyways so I was not
underperforming for my IDO
but I was like okay I'm gonna show up
and I am on the rise and this person has
passed her prime of she was like I don't
know 70 80 points below her pass below
her best pillow ever so I was like okay
this is just I'm showing up I'm winning
this game that was very wrong that's
very wrong mentality in general you show
up and I know I'm not not that because
she's a woman or something another now
that wasn't it he's a 24 to a tee I am
playing with dreams all all day long I'm
gonna beat these players and this
overconfidence can always cost you
something and I learned it the hard way
let's see so if you play a 45 neither
three is six
d4 takes takes and a six I used to play
this Paulson count system back at a time
and it was a a quote called hot opening
at a time was considered that nowadays
after c4 is is a suffering really
there's so many well I mean it's just to
the playable opening but I am not having
fun if if I were to choose a line in
Sicilian two players black that wouldn't
be my first choice
so she she went for c4 Knight f6 Knight
c3 and I'm playing for a wind right I'm
not gonna play Bishop d6 Bishop d7 Queen
c7 and played the hedgehog no no sir I'm
going to play for a win could be sure
before oh sorry Queen c7 I am preparing
the move Bishop before now now this is a
play a3 this for a three to prevent
Bishop Bishop before and this back at
the time he was considered label this
line with this 25 but current analysis
shows that here I don't know exactly
what's the what I don't remember was
'watch best no fear I think maybe we
should be three White's lead in
development alpha is the extra pawn for
black so it's not a recommended
recommended long line so after this a3
these days they play them of b6 and they
still enter the hedgehog with the movie
three four four four white any questions
about that
makes sense are we good all right any
questions from our audience so far
okay so Queen c7 okay my upon played
Bishop e3 and I was like okay this
doesn't sound right this is a sound
right so I played them off the ship
before I was like okay you know he gave
me the moment unbeknownst to me that
she's actually prepared this line so she
played the move Queen b3 and I was like
now can't be right that's next upon the
center well first of all is the Queen
good on b3 what do you think is it a is
it a good play
is it a well-placed piece on v3 that's
the first question we have to answer
let me give everyone a couple of minutes
to think about this position first
what's that
well I mean it wins the temple but the
questions are where it goes after right
it's on the way
because what is white has extra space on
this King side on the Queen side I which
side do you have extra space as white
from white side so the Queen's are right
because of the policy for is all right
and all the weaknesses on p6 or like
this is square or right you can maybe
address it huh and maybe if you can
expand before c5 that would be a nice
square to exploit right of course black
linen just stand and watch but I mean I
also this this bishop but kind of
eyeballing this right make sense so the
coin is not so well placed so even if
you play Bishop c5 practically speaking
this is in the fight I mean the I just
found the game from 2018 I'm not sure if
it's a rapid game or or a classical but
it's a game between Hawaiian Jones who
the Grandmaster who who today just
crossed 2700 for the first time in his
career congratulations to him against
the Grandmaster no man despises from
Latvia and - ok
DeWine heavily out out rate Mises at
this moment but even even he got this
it's a fight I mean he got a very strong
attack but the gaming didn't draw in a
variant I mean okay I'm not sure if if
my display the best fashion but I mean
he kind of kind of tried so and he
managed to hold actually I don't intend
to analyze this part again even if
you're not sure just drop the bishop
back like these six stay slightly Ward's
play on the game right I mean your black
is a sit in the game after Bishop c5
right are we good so my opponent played
could be three I even didn't take any
time well I took some time maybe I'm not
sure I wish i I kept the score sheet but
I mean you don't think about it
so I played the move Bishop takes c3 I
said okay extract pawn in the center huh
who wouldn't take it
I took with the Queen he took me the
Queen I took 94 and I left the
tournament help just doing good and I
was waiting because usually about half
an hour into an hour it was playing you
buy and divide they have this praying a
prayer time break because did because
you know the the [ __ ] players had to
go and say prayers in the mosque okay
I'll wait for that but my important but
what I was walking back I expected my
opponent spending some time at this
moment when I when I was walking back my
point already had made her move can I
guess but what did she play okay keep
looking keep looking
any any comments from our live audience
well why would the writer in this
position
everyone okay
which one
queer three are Scotty six
okay any comment well no one not for
this one all right might be five well
the point is the night is six I take the
D pawn queen g7 okay fit and then I go
nightly selling defending my rook on f8
so the thing is after takes takes now
now after f3 she's prepared to play the
move Bishop to h6 but if if you take on
e6 I'm not sure but I can take take and
I think I first of all I can have this
check which is which is kind of not fun
to meet and then after this this suppose
this move I just simply play 97 right
the rookies defender then I'm just off
of peace
so might be five and that came as a
shock so I did not make him until it was
the the prayers break now I spent
laughing I was like so but you know now
I'm experienced enough when they play
move like this what do i what can I do
except taking it right take that phone
and they think didn't move after not at
this moment so I took them b5 Queen
takes g7 the next move is also forced I
have to remove the rock right here then
I appoint by the f3 well back at the
time and the later later material
materials published in in chess journals
back in the time this was considered
better for white but I was analyzing it
today after such a long time and I
realized it's not that bad actually why
would you do here as black
the question is that what's the best one
for plaque because because well is that
it is that the only thing because we
gave up right now is just an extra piece
right if you give it back
is it that bad because you know why
White King is also vulnerable now the
question is that are you that that much
worse if you give up the peace pact or
not because I approached it with the
same question do I can I keep the peace
because well I was only thinking about
winning the game of course which is a
silly silly wrong mindset what is the
best move in this position for black any
move man who in a five kingi to
d 5f take c4
Bishop h6 or Bishop c5 then I go Bishop
c5 and we lose immediately it's very
hard but I had to deal with it over the
board the clock is ticking and and the
prayers time is over so I try to use an
extra time to think about this position
I couldn't come up with anything
and actually that extra 10 minutes that
that 10 minutes break actually
exasperated situation for him because I
got more nervous because when you have
you in time and to think about it you
start seeing ghosts
so I even was seeing things that they
were not on the board but I was same
thing oh my god my position is really
bad on it but the thing is that I was
still not changing my mindset I was not
trying to equalize or get a fighting
position I was just trying to win
that's straight by maintaining my piece
on the board we're getting somewhere
the final okay 25 check is not see if
our Bishop is a big mistake it's a big
blunder which yeah Queen e5 check King
g2 but then this is the Harmony Knight
f6
takes and B takes before you give up the
exchange back you go d5 97 it's balanced
beautiful computer remove
takes and take on c4 you just give up an
exchange and then it says it's computer
clothes stays close to zero after of
course I have to I have to I have to
analyze it more in detail but this was a
but you know if you if you think in a
proper way you just think about I'm
giving back and then after that I'm up
upon okay that's that dark square Bishop
is a killer but you can always give up
an exchange and then your pawns become
very strong in the center and what also
is not that well develop anymore because
that King blocks the bishop the look is
stuck on each one the rook on it is
already developed right they look on it
doesn't need to move right it's
attacking a 2-part so I need just to
move the deep aisle - tonight on d7
right if I get to do this I'm fine can
we agree on that huh Bishop c5 d6 and
now you forego not e7 the 697 ya Bishop
Bishop c5 we got these six
or maybe I can just play 97 and take and
then be take c4 I don't know can't you
do this now the king is exposed kind of
it's quite interesting quite interesting
yep so the game okay I played this move
Knight c5 my opponent played Bishop h6 I
thought I thought this is the way takes
and then well the thing is that I did
not think about this move I thought I
was thinking only baruk to d1 what's so
good about this move is that in some
lines I was calculating after rook t1
the Queen goes to e7 I have them of
knight c6 but now she maintains the
threat but I can happily knight c6
anymore
so here I played happy 3 yp6 here I
don't know why I put this one right it's
not how the game went actually no wait
excuse me just a second
alright somebody that's hard this is
somebody else's game actually somebody
else in 2016 they reach the same
position and then after this one yeah
the thing is that as you can see these
three pieces are out then white simply
plays Bishop b2 castle and just black is
doomed because the Queen just talked to
the cook on FFA there actually I have to
include this one too so black is
complete you see it's like if if the
pawns and the rook have cut black space
into two house so I place my created
more chances as you can see it's this is
getting dramatic Oh
angular it's getting a dramatic okay the
the move here okay actually this is the
winning move actually okay he missed
this actually I meant excellent okay
sheep first of all she missed a simple
one Queen c3 that's when sunspot
yeah I have to go back before the game
over it's a bad move but in the last
position you have to make a move that
gives you the most amount of chance and
that was the practical so look t1 I'll
put it back on training I don't want you
to see the answers Quinn before check
King after Luke takes a two and she's
pretty very enterprising Bishop c4 now
you know the thing is that as as the
engine analyzes the position it goes
from 0.5 point plus one then goes down
then it's just very hard to say but why
I can say it's more comfortable to play
as white still still now here I had to
go to text me too I had to play it with
XP too
I played the move that's not so great
f6 and actually for but I think may
mention what what's the best no fear I
think this is still okay and I think
this is not the best move f6 was wrong
for some reason and I forgot to include
it do you mind if I run the engine to
check if the what's the best move here
so I don't remember this is this was a
bad move because repite was forced let's
see let's see
and I'm not sure if I remember
this well I take no be should be six is
not doesn't work actually she took it
later and that doesn't work that's kinky
three prepares the move which is still
doesn't work because because Bishop u66
Queen c7 a Quincy five check I have that
move we should be six I take I mean you
can take twice on the face I cannot take
it back but I have enough material to
take on B 297 I'm back in the game
but Queen c7 was her fine but then I
have this check doesn't work let me just
shake I mean this was not at least
fifteen years ago I thought this is not
a good love let me see
of course rupee okay the steps six
doesn't make any sense
but there isn't there's a mafia rupee
under 20 but okay good luck finding that
I mean like stop this thing this is kind
of slow I think any Houdini or something
is fine and it sounds something that is
fast enough yeah okay yeah good luck
finding that by thing is this was this
was not the greatest move anyways so
this f6 and she played King g3 which is
not a great thing
turn it off so King g3 I take on b2 now
it's really getting Germany and I'm
really low on time I have less than five
minutes and it's move 18 and I have to
make 22 moves so I'm really low on time
so what she also doesn't have so much
time I think she has like 10 minutes or
something so she takes on these things
and I'm like what what I mean I got here
no maybe yes so he takes is 6 I played
this one fast there I play this check
first so look at this I'm up to pieces
this I play this check I saved the rook
here it's move 21 I'm at a time that you
would get 30 seconds for each move so I
played this move Queen 7 fast too so I
was back to about five minutes I've made
three moves and I'm winning now it's
completely winning it's a pizza right
it's a compliment well I mean I'm losing
the bishop but it's a it's a simple
piece opposition now so my opponent
plays Queen texier check King here and
plays back from c3 it's it's her best
practical chance actually but it's
totally winning right it's a fat piece
position now why tip now why to play
no it's no oh sorry yeah but if I say
yes it's black to play my bad
and I was like now again then I got so
relaxed I was tense on a side making
good moves for a few months okay you're
kind of more or less forced and then I
was like relax okay I have five minutes
I was no nothing to my I don't know my
friend or my mom I don't know who was
there just getting some coffee and stuff
I'm so so much in charge and that was
again I got too comfortable here which
one that and then if I take a night yeah
I missed that I play look GG - and now
after this unbelievable I have to find
only ways to make a draw
well the thing is I said okay why would
I give up my night on v3 right I just
was okay I said and what bothers me now
and that's what makes it painful I saw
Luke beat XG 2 because the thing is that
even if you don't do that even if you
play six Pete xg2 point xp3 even if I
even if I don't see Quincy five I'm off
a pawn in a winning position just kept
497 and I mean what's gonna get make it
pretty soon 97 95 right and then f5 and
everything everything is coming like
it's just that it's just a matter of
time to win this position and then I
played oh look GG txg - and now I have
to find the only move to make a draw
unbelievable
and what I didn't see now I'll show you
what I didn't see I played in five but
the the draw is rook BC to and after the
Queen takes b3 I think this is bad
so after Queen takes to d3 attacking h7
I go Queen c5 and after check it's
perpetual King yet queen is a check can
get here and you have you have to
perpetual it's going to be a draw
so that was the only move rook miss et
was the only move so here I confidently
play d5 my plan took and I was like I'm
winning I play Queen six chicken I take
the loop next move
keep the Sheep little chief oh I didn't
see rook g4 and I resigned that
differently I came as a shock the movie
for just came as a shock to me I even
you know actually I at least could take
on G to hear Queen xp3 King b3 takes
take on at six and down an exchange most
likely losing but I can make few more
moves and it's in time pressure
something can happen right I thought I
saw her win this King moves the rock
that is defended by detective Brooke I'm
waiting I don't think she played this
move the funny thing is that she can
even play King g3 I didn't see that one
yeah well that's the son learned I
completely had a focus issue in this
enter this entire game whenever you go
to a game you have to make it so
important to you that you only think
about it only think about the game okay
the first painful painful loss well but
she had a good prep and she cannot
really interesting ideas Bishop c4 all
the cb5 so I think I didn't know that
she deserve to win any questions well
but one of the chatters asked what would
happen if rook takes rook doesn't that
still also drop in which moment no
Brooke I play rock PC to hear now you
mean rook takes rook what I'll take over
here
the problem is that you wanna go Queen
c5 here now but then I have a check here
III think it's it's quite it's
questionable if if I can save save this
because if I played this I think there's
this check and then if I take chicken as
a queen h5 maybe but then what if I take
here
wait what then can't I just pick up
material yeah I'm not sure I think I
think g1 is is losing that's why
actually that's why I thought when I
took on g2 I thought I would be 5 I
think g1 is already this check and the
rook is hanging just double threat so
Quimby 3 I mean what about this I mean I
don't know
yeah this is nothing clean before
doesn't work anyways anyways yeah that
was painful
so the next one happened summer after
this one
this was another hiccup who which
prevented me uh to kind of improve and
get them get closer to the GM title so
the final thing is that before the game
they told me this guy gets a lot gets
his points the upsets by getting lucky
against the stronger players and that
kind of got under my skin a lot of time
I wasn't I was trying to make the safe
choices and that's where I ended up
blundering less this is the interesting
story I was already I'd say
psychologically I was kind of living on
the mind I was like this guy okay let me
show you the game first is the next
button here
any questions
oh wait wait is it go okay this is oh
this is not safe correctly oh no it's
not the game at this point so yeah yes
four became friends after that actually
in future tournaments so I play my
opening so that's good
in all those confidence is still play
your openings don't lose confidence this
is a how many month after four month
after more or less so so he went for
this Knight c3 he wanted to play this
this this RC forward but Knight c3 was
more common at a time than c4 nasty for
a thing is more common at this I see it
more often in the GM level games three I
play Bishop I think this is already
nothing
nothing not the right move I have to I
have to check my old notes but this is
already not a good enough hours I used
to play this move with the idea of after
Castle I played this move knight c6
early on and then if they if they
capture I can so I really like to the
idea of neutralizing this 9:24 good
knight c6 and then after after I take
the take with the bishop I would like to
go 97 96 to attack this Bishop on d4 so
that's what but I think this is not
exactly correct so I have to go this one
I think this is the best move now with
this although Chris she has many nice
swings in this position as well from
White's a name is this castle I play
Queen c7 after 2005 and I became a GM I
started playing them of 96 this mode I
think if you just go a 498 to c3 black
is already in some trouble this is not
the best setup I can I cannot afford
making all these ones on the Queen side
without developing the Kings side so I
think this is already suspicious again
f4 but again this is not the right
approach this is what you want to see in
this opening from black side you go
aggressive against the King sir but the
thing is that when you go to aggressive
this pieces
and if this denied on JIT and the bishop
on the faith actually well-placed
they're ready to react actually because
if you go f5 ago if i've i come might
have six right away after I can flip
bishops if I work with ship before or
even if you go f5 I can play Bishop d6
put the bishop on e5 which controls a
lot of scores right like if this happens
then you can do this now you can use
this square so kind of I I am ready
actually to react to this position so I
play Bishop to c5 first Bishop b3 I play
knight c6 my favorite move he goes 92 so
far so good
no tactics right I mean moves like this
if the king is on it's fun you can but
no tactics right now because this is
hanging 9 f6 I expected them of king
each one but he played this off be 5
doesn't make any sense right 94 and he
played Queen d2 now what do we do here
any questions all right we were 22
seconds until
that night nice seat xe5 and yeah and
yell and inflate anyone said 1965 nobody
said that
yes f65 I just just take the Queen mate
and the bishop and his bishop at four
runs into this one game over so well at
least he had to try something he he
played the move rook AE one then I was
like thank you and thank you I got both
bishops Knights are crippled when it
comes to attacking so I was like okay
I'm set castle and I'm set done central
pawn up to bishops and no attack now
here he played Eric King which one now
if you want to finish this game you know
the winning move I had this we had this
Wiseman when I was back in Iran now he
would come to torment she was Iran's
champ a long time ago but he was a PhD
was a philosopher as well very nice
interesting guy unfortunately passed
away he passed away too early he was
saying the video he's not the one he's
not the best of all is the one that
makes you up on the resign so what will
make my opponent resign in this position
central pawn up to bishops open position
screwed up on the structure for
- two moves would make your opponent
resign very early in this game
- kind of mousse
somebody almost whispered if that was
right yeah that's one of the moves just
kill the counterplay Queen b6 rook c8
p55 trade everything on the C file on
your winning there's another one there's
another plan to as a slow and as
possible as a slow and easy yet this
game has such an impact on me let me
tell you some background back a
background story about this one so I I
was late for tournament so they appeared
me against the countryman of mine who
was also back at a time late for a
tournament so we agreed on and drove it
up playing which is kind of weird but
that's there was no other way we were we
were on our way our flight got delayed
five times five times so we just arrived
before almost first run was halfway
through so we called it a draw then we
don't have won a game and then in the
third round I played I played against
the Grandmaster - Ian from from Armenia
and I lost a horrible game from
Whiteside like absolutely horrible so I
was thinking I have to win this one and
I come back to a tournament all right
and I'm like playing I've always thought
for like I don't know 15 minutes 20
minutes in the game and I'm winning move
16 I'm winning this is like game over
doesn't matter who is your point even
against Michael Scott said this is very
very very winning his position no
countable nothing so I was like I just
wanna practice for now and go home
wrong attitude again wrong attitude
there's a the only thing that matters is
to win the game so you have to make a
move gradually just improve your
position the second way yeah yeah I get
before I explain it the second idea
well Queen if I'm also you don't really
need that because the route goes to have
to the Queen ninety-five can it's good
it's good the Queen ninety-five the
qualifier is good but then you can go F
65 rook a e8 oke 8f 65 yeah
not right away you got 26 25 or just
Queen d6 took 88 f65 done done easy
right
piece of cake what I did Queens okay
still winning state plus for f5 alright
I made a right move this now I played
another right move he played this now
just take honey 5 and play f6 right
dismissed they going back to e3 and then
like not Queen d6 right I'm 25
game over right and if the crew goes to
g1 black is too white is totally tied
down then you go King FC naruki 8 you
bring the ragazza to the game black what
is absolutely out of love absolutely any
questions pen so far nothing okay so I
play Queen d8 okay no big deal I still
it's plus 393 okay that nice is now you
have a game like this and you're not
feeling confident just trade everything
you can what's that d6 yeah Queen f4 now
it starts getting with it so I see this
nut so the easiest way is to play look
here Queen a 5-week have fun take the
pawn right there I can get cheat because
Europe defends it and then you're up to
pawns the Queen comes back to d5 no
threats really not just selling like
Queen takes p2 now I'm making my
opponent
right so Queenie if I pick up the second
part the position is open you always can
suck it exchange one of the bishops
there's not enough material to checkmate
you right as long as you stay what
active I wasn't active so I played the
move g6 which is fine and here okay
here's the story I have over an hour my
opponent is less than five minutes and
then here I was just like dude I just
wanna go home
I'm winning and in the inspiration he
played him of 90 f5 very good very good
practical decision
he's losing anyways right so we take you
right then he played d4 now it's a
judgment question where do you put the
bishop
Bishop before okay
and he answers better
no that's not a problem I just go I mean
yeah that's that can be a problem yeah
now you need to calculate now you need
to calculate actually you need to be
very very accurate in your move order
you cannot just play by feelings here
and that was our mistake I made here I
just felt like anything should be
winning I just need to win a tempo it's
a basis to take the point and here I
kept with it but just for for couple of
minutes I was fast I was doing tactics
every day I was in a good shape at a
time so just saw small continuation and
I was like opening so I played this I
play Bishop before which blew away the
wind he played he played I touch fives
which is actually more accurate than
Queen h6 and now my only move to keep me
in the game is the move Bishop to d2
after takes a Queen h4 I'm actually
slightly better still but when your
mindset is that I'm winning you're not
looking so I had calculate this line and
that's why I'd be the bishop on b6 it
makes sense another painful part is that
I told myself it doesn't matter I saw
Bishop e6 is winning that's why I choose
this game because I think in my opinion
painful losses are not just the ones
that are like it was money though I've
changed I mean some some of them are
life changes just so I'm done with the
game you become so fed up and everything
but the the biggest pain still in my
opinion is the one that oh you see it
this is winning and they play something
else what's that look what
no no I play King getcha which isn't
blunder Queen h6 rocks you and rook e8
and the thing is if the bishop is on
business I made I take on g2 check take
94 mate
and the thing I saw this I took country
to check he played this I resigned
because I didn't say pick up sticks
check he goes Queen g7 mate I didn't see
this with my calculation I forgot about
this I I didn't see I thought I keep a
check I take a look at my winning that's
why I say it doesn't matter where I put
the bishop all right
I froze when I think about Iceland
better get a goose bump because I saw a
shabby sixes winning and unless it
doesn't matter where I put the bishop
I didn't even you come come first you
see a win clear win and I play that move
it this one can be painful right
especially I almost play Bishop c6 that
could have appeared on the board
actually between g7
well the tournament went really down the
drain it was it was really a bad
tournament just I was going to lose a
bunch of Elah points just got lucky last
round I got prayer against someone my
own rating and ended in down the palm
position he blunders but it wasn't as if
waiting for him as this one so so it
wasn't as bad so I got to sometime been
any questions I think I think it's okay
what's that yeah well I do too I do too
I have to admit it's very beautiful now
all right I'm in the process of coming
up with an idea for a book and I'm one
in one of the chapters I want to talk
about how to learn best from your losses
and this was definitely will make it to
that book any tactic book anything this
is a very beautiful position I mean
think about it
white black has a discovered check to
bishops on the board vice getting mated
any questions from from everyone here so
I could come up with something else but
not that they wouldn't be as into
enterprising as these two games I just
had shown you so instead were you I
thought I'll pick up something from
recent games played in the Champions
between T'Pol off and what I cannot say
how painful could be for T'Pol off of
course he can talk for himself but I
just want to talk about the suffering so
and let's learn something Game two this
one is very interesting who explained it
in a in the puzzle puzzle paradise on
Sunday and it almost took the entire
class an entire class so I am not sure
if you have time but I first want to
show you that the problem of not it's
not the first position I want to show
you how to the super
so
our biggest enemy when we lose obvious
games in a sense is compressors I'm not
saying the pod was compressing because
58 games move 58 moves game number 8 he
is not as professionals he used to be so
anything and and you're playing ding
leerin so it's intimidating but this is
obvious to all right white is down an
h-bomb so if you get the H point give up
to e pawn that h1 is more advanced you
can you can get your King back and and
maintain the fluid or position right it
doesn't take so much so why would the
power play King at five
why wouldn't you play King f3 right
isn't that right hmm I go with my king
to win the pan right can you have 16g
fork okay three take okay three yeah I
mean go Cafe checked then taking a king
g4 and then you just try to trade the
rooks on f3 and put the King on with you
so that's what that should be a draw
anyways he plays King get five my ex his
life will be difficult now in this
moment he can go to p8 and it's going to
be a draw h2 now I can get six Turkish
okay why okay to take only five King g5
you're a punk goes fast as well and you
decide to look for the H bar it's going
to be a draw make sense so then you
waste another temple not and now here
Dingley refines this King get six still
a draw if you got a piece ever he goes
rocky eight and now and nothing little
plays okay Sarah not life gets
uncomfortable
aha now you're gonna have problem when
something very easy turns into something
as a problem is this a silly draw then
you start to suffer and it is
psychologically extremely extremely
difficult to handle
so rookie it doesn't work to kt7 right
the key and and that's because of the
king of five because not the king is far
from the village fine you cannot afford
that so you have to use the rook to get
back
so he goes rook rook b8 right delteros
gotta get in front of h 2 rupees six
check its force actually because if you
go why the chick is forced
I don't remember look t1 was not a good
move
I repeat VAR I think g7 lukkage chuan
rook chief ah okay
Ruchi one I think g5 check your cage
five yes
I think this because I'm fighting with
g1 now who catch one look g5 check and
then I go to go catch five
everything is under control that h5
score is important so he found it's good
enough so you know it's the part of one
of the best players in the chess history
if you wanna name 25 player in terms of
strength definitely to Paulo is one of
them in the entire history of chess so
h2 he finds this check because the
Scourge vibe should be filled with a
piece which is the rook which is the
King now King h5 rugby one King gage for
he goes G for now
these guys move 64 playing six hours so
far like a machine plays rook e7 okay
one you have to wait King F 6 doesn't
work you get yourself ever
you get yourself away from the e pawn
see you have to just stay they make
field had a few moves and then he starts
giving the side check ok now I cannot
make any progress but it's still very
annoying right super annoying he goes
Rakesh it takes root King g3 look h1
kingi to take ok this is a draw if you
put table busts it says a draw but again
let's look at this thing later finds a
way to force Y to promote tonight that
was a draw King f3 take the palm put a
rock on f3 is a draw now play our 50
moves the game could end on move maybe
65 with a simple draw and now another 50
most other 30 moves so they keep on
playing let me just say I will not be
able to complete this but I just give
you some idea I might follow this
actually on Thursday and Thursday
lectures if you come back I'll make sure
that I'll cover in one of lectures g5
they're playing a still doing good until
they get to this position so so far is
defending just just fine he goes route
f3 now here here is where the tragedy
happens
while the night night has two scores to
go 96 loses to Brooke t3 night of seven
King f6 and this is x1 now at the 6:53
night of seven King f6 and it's a Suk's
walk
so either 97 or 97
now g7 what he was doing against the
rock on f1 which it works but it does
not work against the look on f3 it's
very illogical but that's the fact then
drawing move is let me close this I
can't explain it to you I wish I had the
amount of time but the thing is that
this is losing ninety seven is the is
the drawing move ninety-seven loses and
the remaining always king of six because
nothing else can improve the position
king of six now White has okay the least
the the idea is that what I would have
understood is that you try to confine
the neither Angie said I put the King on
his seven and get your look to the fifth
rank and then the night is is still
mated
that's the plan the King only seven the
look on e5 or g5 and the night when g7
is submitted
so close king of six suppose I cannot eh
check if you learn to win this one the
rest are just trying to transport the
position into this that's a lot it's a
lot of work it's a lot work I will just
spend a few minutes explain this one and
then I live their entire thing to
another full lecture maybe it takes at
least it took 15 minutes on Sunday to go
over it with everyone and still nobody
excelled at it I cannot simply I cannot
say I know everything about this
position and I've spent at least 45
hours working on this so
okay sorry and this is the key everybody
is thinking that the movies should be
Luke g3r oops you want something like
that right yeah Luke g3 is a draw King
get seven can give 795 I'm sorry
Knight is five king each six and the
night then I just everything flips 90
degree it's not loose it rotates 90
degrees sorry so Rakesh sorry I am I'm
working on confining the denied 95
checked in here not there rocked III I
am pushing the night back 98 and so
night of seven loses immunity 98 check
is the mode 9 f7 destructive for NRT 7
if 98 are waiting in 98 I go that it's
this one transposes - what
now this is not this okay I think I may
I put the wrong continuation 98 is
losing because let me check sorry I
think I just put the wrong move here now
rocked III not know III is not this is
right this Oh
now remember no no no I told you come to
the fifth Frank I forgot another look
stop sit the rukon of three doesn't work
because it cannot go to f5 neither look
neither of stops okay now I remember
okay get the King to e7 to simplify the
formula is to get the King on his have a
look on the fifth rank that's winning
now for example King at seventh King f7
right
good question
I think I messed up let me see
ah but I can go here
because this is what's that
hmm no I cannot give you know I should I
should not give you that you're right
hmm what about King f8 King afraid yeah
Ginga faith because King gets King at
six do not have this check and a button
but then you can go here but I go look
down look down this is no rock dude yes
because if you if you if you if you get
your night away from the king then
tennis it's over no but I looked it mate
if you go 95
yeah okay [ __ ]
and finally found it and you see there's
a lot of tricks here and the entire
thing is that this is the winning
position the entire idea is that this is
the winning position you want to get to
this position to leverage three every
other position transposed to this one if
the second rank when you go to act III
whoopty whoop Dee - there's nothing
so you flavor acacia tree check here now
they're gonna at least six to go duck t3
if the rookies on - - if you looked if
there's ninety four check if it's on one
if it's on one the the night comes to e4
and goes to g3 something something with
that 94 checking out because 94 check
the thing is that in this line if Knight
goes to e4 check you go King f5 there's
no g3 check but when they rookies on the
Evander's 93 check
yeah I think that was the reason so
there Luke should be on d3 avoiding the
night before check and avoiding the
night g3 check because you go - yeah if
you go g6 i working fi yeah from that
was that that was the only you don't
lose your chance because you can
maneuver back to get it it's a still
winning but you have too much you don't
make any improvement that's the point
you don't make an improvement the rook
should be on the third rack I will I
will Sorrell you as you can see I have
spent hours analysis and I still cannot
remember everything right I will cover
this spin when can we do this can't
cover this end game even of the class
maybe yeah either so do we do do we
record on what Sunday - I don't know
it's all right okay well I think we try
to have it some cover some day you start
doing investigators yep it's a lot of
work but anyways thank you for joining
me today
tonight we learn something very fun
together I think this is the fun part
but I had to respect the title and talk
about my losses first but this is quite
something
well thank you thank you
you
[Music]